welcome to episode 44 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this is an episode co-hosted by my papa
jordan peterson
i don't know why i just called him papa
i don't normally call him papa
we interviewed former fbi negotiator
chris voss
chris voss is an american businessman
author and the ceo
of the black swan group limited which
teaches people how to negotiate
he co-authored never split the
difference
a book on how to negotiate and
documenting his experience as an fbi
negotiator
i wanted to speak to him for a while
because i'm stubborn to a ridiculous
degree sometimes and was always told i
have to compromise
by giving away some of what i want in
order to get along with people
so a book called never split the
difference sounded right up my alley
you'll hear more about whether it's
necessary to compromise in this episode
this episode is brought to you by ground
news a sponsor of the show and a
canadian company i really support
their comparison platform for news so
rather than trying to find an unbiased
news platform which is virtually
impossible ground news will compare how
sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
so you can easily see whether or how
outlets are manipulating a story to fit
an underlying narrative
very necessary in current times they'll
show an article and then it'll say
something like 60
left 27 center 13 right something like
that
they have an app called ground news for
your phone so check that out
ground news is an apolitical news app
only interested in giving you the full
story regardless of your political
ideology
i recommend downloading the free ground
news app and browser extension
you can click in the description below
or go to ground
dot news because it's the new year i
also wanted to mention my dad made a
code
mp for 15 off his self
authoring suite it's a writing program
that gets you to go through your past
present and future to figure out what
you want to do
to navigate how to do that in other
words
it allows you to write out your past to
go through unresolved traumas
issues to figure out what's going on in
your present life and to figure out a
future you'd like to live in
what i find is incredibly helpful is it
gets you to write out a future
that would occur if you let your bad
habits get out of control
the negative view of what a future could
realistically be like is a great reason
to form good habits
and turn your future into what you want
we're not really taught how to goal set
properly
and i find this is an invaluable
no-frills
tool for people trying to accomplish
things and get somewhere
codemp for selfauthoring.com for 15
off fantastic for new year's resolutions
my resolution is finished my book that
i've been working on for
a very very long time i hope you guys
enjoy this episode
i did we're sitting close to each other
because one of my mics wouldn't work
so chris waited for us for half an hour
this has never happened before and it
works now it worked right after the
episode but it didn't work that day
so we're sharing a mic also if you enjoy
the
episode remember to subscribe happy
[Music]
listening
[Music]
okay well we're very pleased to have
with us today us being the kdr peterson
jordan peterson uh chris boss
who's currently ceo of black swan
consulting
uh was formerly the fbi's talk
kidnap international kidnapping
negotiator
and uh is the author of never split the
difference
a book offering to teach its readers
the fine art of successful negotiation
thanks very much for joining us today
chris i enjoyed your book a lot and i'm
looking forward to your stories
yeah thank you it's my pleasure it's
awesome to be on with you guys
much appreciated um
why do you i'm interested in negotiation
because i'm a clinical psychologist
and a lot of what clinical psychologists
do is
negotiate with their clients for
behavioral change but also teach their
clients to
negotiate successfully with the people
around them to get what they want
so negotiate and negotiation is very
underdeveloped skill in most people
right so i'm wondering
how you came to develop an and we'll go
from there
well let me quote the great uh i like to
say quote great actor rocky balboak and
i couldn't sing a dance i was you know i
was with the fbi i was a swat guy
um i had to get out of swat because of
recurring injuries
but i want to stay in crisis response
and so you know we had hostage
negotiators i knew they were around i
didn't know what they do
didn't seem that hard right you know i
could i could talk to terrace is what i
thought
um got into it it was fantastic it was
you know i had had to sort of
fight my way in not really fight my way
and i had to work to get in i was
eminently unqualified before i became a
negotiator but
my first step was to volunteer on a
suicide hotline and
you know the opportunity to influence
people in short periods of time blew me
away
in really counterintuitive methods and
one thing led to another i taught
negotiation at harvard
and collaborated on a book with some
people and uh been teaching negotiation
ever since it's just been
it's phenomenal it's it's great to have
a positive impact i'm sure as you feel
you know you have a
you have the opportunity to have a
positive impact on people it's
enormously satisfying
so why what made you think that the
skills that you had picked up as a
negotiator in these crisis situations
would be applicable to
people in their day-to-day concerns
yeah you know great question i mean i
suspected early on
when i was volunteering on the hotline
like is this just
people in crisis or is it just people
and i started using the skills in my
day-to-day life it you know and it
it it impacted all my relationships and
made me a better hostage negotiator
and when i first started collaborating
with harvard and uh
they invited me to come and attend uh
the law school's negotiation course
instructors up there were teaching were
saying like look man you're doing the
same thing we're doing that
the stakes are different but the
dynamics are absolutely the same
that was you know what was sort of their
blessing and their understanding
ended up teaching that later but the
dynamics are same it's
human behavior regardless of what the
circumstances are we're wired in certain
ways
and as human beings we all have the same
wiring as you know
so i'm going to get into some of your
what would you call tactical strategies
i guess and
speaking of the clinical connection i
when i was reading your book
the first thing that came to mind is
that the techniques in general sounded
very much like those that were put forth
by carl rogers to ensure
successful clinical uh transformation
and lo and behold about halfway through
the book you
make direct reference to carl rogers and
he was a great
well he was really the formalizer i
think of the idea of
of active listening and reflection
particularly the idea that you should
put yourself in the shoes of the other
person
but also to ensure that you're hearing
them properly you should
uh repeat what they said back to them in
paraphrased manner
and see if you actually got the gist of
their conversation
right so to some degree you concentrate
on that i guess in the section
well it's not so much labeling statement
mirroring i guess is your is your term
with the pause
well you know there's a couple i mean we
we've really sort of
really defined all the different skills
in real specific detail and that you
know i was one of the things that the
harvard guy said to me because
we're on the same path but the fbi we're
a little bit further down it and
they said you know we're both talking
about the same skills you've defined
them and
with much more clarity because
principally
law enforcement you know cops fbi agents
you know we want specifics on how to do
something and then and we'll take it
we'll road test it so
mirroring versus labeling we would call
two different things
and even the different types of labels
and you know we take
we take what we learn with the world
learn we collective mankind and
psychology and we added neuroscience
we started trying to hit very specific
parts of the brain to create
very specific reactions so yeah
mirroring
i would define mirroring is repeating
the last one to three words of what
someone just said or selected one to
three words
versus labeling i'm looking for
emotional nuances
dynamics well one of the things that
struck me with labeling is that
you know people might respond positively
to that we should
i'll let you define it momentarily but
people should respond positively to that
because
it's often the case that when people are
in a discussion or negotiating
that they don't actually know what
they're bringing to the table or what
they want and so
if they're floundering about in a
somewhat emotion
written and stressed manner
and you put your finger on what it is
that they're trying to say
then you're actually articulating
something for them that's still only
being processed at the level of bodily
response
and people find that a great relief if
you can do it accurately because you've
summed up
a very complicated set of
physiological disturbances with that
with a single utterance and
kind of enable them to see the pathway
forward
yeah no absolutely and you can even it
doesn't even have to be that accurate
you know and which is the thing that
neuroscientists taught us you know
oxytocin dopamine depend upon
what neurochemicals being hit i mean
when you're inaccurate
and they correct you they actually get a
hit of dopamine
which they love i mean people hate being
corrected but they love to correct it's
a great way to create a bond that the
other person doesn't even know is being
built
well and if you're incorrect and you're
labeling at least the person then has
something they can object to that's
concrete
you talk about that a bit right the
importance of getting somebody to say no
that was interesting like is it possible
to describe that a little bit
yeah that was one of the craziest words
and
we you know hearing it we're taught when
we're little
you know what's the first word every
child learns no
yeah and they love that word yeah yeah
they get hammered with it over and over
again so
what condition that when we hear we've
done something wrong but at the same
time we're conditioned when we say it
we protected ourselves so if i get you
to say no
you feel protected you're going to want
to talk you're going to you're going to
feel good about the interaction you're
not going to
feel threatened you're more likely to
open up i mean even something as little
as
nobody in my company says to anybody
have you got a few minutes to talk
it's always is now bad time to talk
complete change in the other side's
reaction
right and so you say instead uh
is this a bad time to talk right okay
right
or even like i won't say is this a good
idea
i'll say is this a dumb idea and you you
probably go like no it's not a dumb idea
but here are the following problems
here's what we got to do
i mean it's a complete change in
reaction yeah well you know if you watch
two-year-olds with no because they they
really latch onto that word it's really
remarkable
and the reason for that is that it
enables them to protect themselves
against
being hijacked by other people right
it's it's actually the word that defines
the boundary between them and the world
and enables
them to have some mortality it's amazing
i i remember i babysat little kid at one
point
or maybe it was my old son it might have
been julian no i think it was a kid ups
babysitting he was unbelievably stubborn
little kid
and uh i i was trying to get him to do
something
just to interact with me and i offered
him a bunch of different
um enticements
you as a psychologist is having trouble
getting a two-year-old to cooperate
well this was a particularly this is a
particularly uh stubborn little
two-year-old but
he he felt known
no no no this was this was truly this
was truly the neighbor's child
actually but he was willing to say no to
m m's and ice cream
which was where he caught himself when
he noticed that he had said it
but the no was such an attractive
proposition to him that he was willing
to forego
even basic immediate rewards just for
the thrill of being able to maintain
that autonomy
yeah so we should go through your
technique left yeah your techniques and
with some um order so i'm gonna
read a couple and maybe you could just
describe what
what what you mean by them so you have
tactical empathy
for example yeah sure i mean
we're trying to take first of all the
point of calling it that was taking it
out of
today's common usage of empathy is
sympathy
or or even compassion now i would argue
that uh
i would i would offer that empathy is a
very compassionate thing to do
but you know going back to the real
reason i first started collaborating
with harvard
you know they said empathy is not
agreement it's not sympathy it's not
even liking the other side it's just
completely understanding
the basic song from rogers in psychology
the stuff that
anybody that's pursued this is study
now let's add in neuroscience tactically
tactically we know that the amygdala is
kind of the
crossroads of all our thoughts and it's
wired to be negative 75
negative and tactically we know that
simply identifying a negative diminishes
not denying it identifying it you think
i'm a jerk
and no i don't think you're that much of
a jerk by saying that you've
diminished it in the other side so let's
just put a tactical application to our
empathy knowing that the negative
emotions
are have four times the impact or eat at
least
on people's thinking so let's approach
and come in through a different door
and it's tactical because well this is
something that
that needs to be clarified too is that
when you're negotiating what is it that
you're striving to attain do you think
it's
and if it's a win you know people
conceptualize that
the success of a negotiation in
different ways it could be you
win which means you get what you want it
could be win-win
in which case both people get what they
want you can go beyond that because you
could say that in a really successful
negotiation
people even discover new things they
didn't know they wanted them to get
those too
so you know
tactical towards what end if you had a
philosophy of negotiation what might
that be
you know it's if the philosophy is great
collaboration which requires long-term
relationships
and ideally every deal
kicks stuff out that you didn't expect
that delighted you which is going to
addict you to want to
continue to deal with me great long-term
relationship if every if
every deal we're in you're delighted you
can't wait to do another one
right so that's absolutely crucial
because it puts within a real moral
framework right because
otherwise you could learn to negotiate
for psychopathic reasons which would be
only short-term interest of yourself
but if you put it in a framework where
you're trying to set yourself up to play
repeatedly with the same person or
with a whole variety of different people
then an ethic automatically enters into
you
right your reputation precedes you i
mean you get a reputation for doing
nothing but good for people
people line up to do business with you
right exactly and reputation is actually
the marker for your
utility as a long-term partner yeah
yep how did that work with specifically
fbi negotiations
i mean if you're dealing with somebody
like a hostage taker how does that end
up
being a win for them yeah well first of
all the crazy thing
is hostage negotiators have reputational
concerns
you know we we have repeat customers
and even if even if the guy that we're
dealing with
even if he goes to jail it never comes
out
how we handle them is going to get into
the media so reputation
is an immediate concern and and you know
people
people are so driven by where it's taken
them in a long run
i mean if somebody has a vision of the
future
no matter how far down the line that
vision is
that's a good thing now we got something
to talk about and
you know my first response with a bank
robber
is really going to be sounds like you
want to survive
of course they do otherwise they'd have
come out and gotten shot already
now we got something to talk about
how do you deal with the people who
don't want to survive
you can pick that up pretty quickly you
know you're going to know right off the
bat you
if you if you're there to hear it and
the analogy
in the business world not everybody
wants to do the deal with you maybe they
want to exploit you maybe they want to
take advantage of you maybe they see it
as a one-off
maybe they're playing you for a fool you
you've got to pick that up in in your in
your everyday negotiations as well
and you'll hear it if you're open to
hearing it
it's it's avoiding preconceived notions
is what really shuts you down being too
focused on a goal gives you
gives you tunnel vision well i really i
really like the um repeated
game analogy you know the
one of the things i've lectured about is
that you tell your children
it isn't important whether they win or
lose it's important how they play the
game
you do but you do yeah but you don't
yeah
but you don't necessarily understand
what that means why you're telling your
child that and they might say well
it's obviously important that i win so i
don't know what you're telling me but
the goal of proper play is to be invited
to play as many games as possible
not to win that particular game even
though you also want to win that
game so you lay out this ethic which is
to make yourself
the best collaborator the most desirable
possible collaborator
across the longest term with the largest
number of people and then you can put
these techniques to use which out
without them being
cold harsh um what
techniques of manipulation
yeah well i was going to say the big
difference between manipulation and
influence
is really where are you taking me
manipulation is when i'm trying to hurt
you
influence is what i'm trying to help you
same set of skills but where are you
coming from where you're trying to go
right right and with the most business
relationships people get cynical about
this but most business relationships are
in fact relationships
you know i was really struck by this
it's even more so in the business world
than it is in the academic world because
in the academic world you put forward a
claim
and at least in the more scientifically
oriented fields
the validity of your claim is dependent
on the degree to which you follow
proper scientific procedure so there's
an
objective way of assessing your
your ability but in business it's a lot
softer than that in some manner because
the measurement techniques for assessing
the other person's ability aren't so
clearly there
and so relationship becomes crucial
and and it's very interesting to me
to understand negotiation
as the um
as the like the skill that makes
capitalism
intensely human because it
brings it under this under the necessity
of
it shows how tightly associated
successful business development
is with playing the game with other
people properly
and it that helps you avoid cynicism
about the entire process i would say
yeah i i agree completely i mean you
know our co-author i mean the book was
written between myself my son brandon
and tal roz
now tall is a brilliant dude i mean i
would read anything any business book
that he's written
i don't know that i'd read any of his
poetry but i'd read his business books
and one of the things that he pointed
out to us is by definition as a species
the only ones of us that survived were
the ones that collaborated were
hard wired to collaborate so if you
increase your collaboration skills more
people are going to want to do business
with you and to your point
it's not always that measurable in an
immediate number
it may be a secondary a tertiary benefit
but you become wealthy by being a great
collaborator
is there any difference between
negotiating just across the board with
women versus men
well that's a loaded question that's for
sure i didn't mean that i just
we're going to get into the differences
between men and men and women i would
love to do that because
um women pick this style of negotiation
up faster than the men do
now at the top end and we've got some
fairly
you know qualitative data to back that
up
um women are
it's hard and there's so much nurture
going on it's hard to separate nature
from nurture
women are nurtured more to pick up on
emotions sooner
they're they're nurtured more to pick up
on soft power sooner
and have an appreciation for emotional
dynamics
and how to use soft power and so that's
why i think that women have a tendency
to be better at this i mean some
some of the people that are great
negotiators are the biggest fans of are
women
did you say you said soft power
yeah well little boys and little girls
little boys are taught to fight little
girls
uh the women that bring them up know
that inevitably they're not going to be
the more physically powerful
so they are they are nurtured early on
to figure out how to get things without
physically fighting over
how do you keep your emotions under
check when you're negotiating
that is the challenge you know and
depending upon
you know there's a couple different
hacks
and they all take practice just like any
other soft skill
if you're genuinely curious it's not
possible to get upset if you can stay in
a genuinely genuinely curious frame of
mind
you're one of the people i'm also a big
fan of stephen kotler he talks about the
psychology of flow
highly positive state of mind curiosity
is
positive you're smarter your brain is
quicker
and when you're genuinely curious you
can't get angry um
interesting cat i run across recently
daryl davis
daryl davis black musician who taught
talks klu klux klan members into quittin
a clan
and i had a conversation with him about
it and
people say why how do you not get upset
with these people
that you know you're a black dude they
they openly say that they want to
murder you he says well i grew up
internationally i just look at it as a
different culture and i'm just
completely curious about
where they're coming from and what are
they thinking about it leaves him in a
state of mind where he can deal with
people that are against him
personally but he's just curious about
it that's interesting
you know one of the most
useful general psychological techniques
in relationship to life
and its challenges is voluntary
exploration
and it's a particular physiological mode
of being
its very old brain center known as the
hypothalamus which controls basic drives
like
hunger and thirst and temperature
regulation defensive aggression
and part of it also controls exploration
and so
if you switch into a mode of voluntary
exploration that's
that's a mode of being that's deeply
hardwired and that
envelops your entire being but
it it allows you to pick up information
right
and we are information scattered with
human beings and so
uh and that's because you can trade
information for valuable things like
food you know so um
if you if you're in this i was struck in
your book by your emphasis on
unknown unknowns black swans you called
them at the end
you said like if you're listening very
carefully to people you can pick up
these unknown unknowns
and that is a consequence of voluntary
exploration
and having it's useful to pick up on
those not only for the conversation that
you're
you're having presently but because of
what the consequences for that
conversation might be for conversations
down the road and so the man that you
just described
he opens himself up he says well these
people are from a completely different
culture than me
maybe there's some valuable things i can
learn from them
regardless of our differences in opinion
and
and those things are of such value that
they might be
portable and it is unbelievably useful
to approach the world in that
matter because then everyone you
encounter is a goldmine of information
especially if they don't agree with you
because they're full of assumptions you
don't have and and you can find out
something new as a consequence that's
way better than just having your own
opinions uh bolstered
which is reassuring but it doesn't
offer you anything new
yeah all those things are completely
true i mean
and by definition the unknown unknowns
is really where the hidden stuff
overlaps
in any given interaction the other side
is hiding stuff i'm hiding stuff
how do we know what happens when we when
when the hiddens overlap
that's why the deal can always be made
better
i like that
that's cool now that's cool
yeah that is cool uh i think for
another practical question hi
practically you guys didn't tell me this
was going to be a practical interview i
thought we were just going to have some
fun
dad dad has fun i i just asked these
practical questions repeatedly in my
podcast
so i'm glad you've got the combination
but uh if you're
trying to like i think the one
negotiation that would benefit everyone
is how to go to whoever they're working
for and try and get more money
look for a raise and i know especially
if you're more agreeable a lot of a lot
of people are worried about that and
have no idea where to start so do you
have tips for
negotiating a raise yeah sure get off
the get you know
raises the price term in any negotiation
you know your salary pays your bills but
it doesn't build your career
you know price takes care of the
immediate problems what are your
long-term problems your long-term
problems or how do you build a career
job negotiations should be about
building your career making yourself
more valuable to the team
and one of two things is going to happen
your salary is going to get drug along
as a result
or if it's not you're more valuable
and you shop yourself to the highest
better
now how you become more valuable you
know
here's a phrase for every job
negotiation
for every annual review
how can i be guaranteed to be involved
in the strategic projects that are
critical to the company's future
instantaneous change in the way your
employer views you
because when you go in and ask for a
raise
empathy is about how does the other side
see you the other side sees you is
selfish
and most employers most bosses whenever
the employee comes walking in the door
they're after something for themselves
you condition your boss that you're
selfish you may not like that reality
but that's unfortunately the reality
when you change their conversation to
how can i help us
all prosper now suddenly your boss your
employer goes like home
now here's somebody i want to have
around here's somebody's got to make my
life better
conversation is instantly transformed
now either you'll get
more money you'll have greater
experiences because also you don't want
to be involved in a mundane at work
you want to if you're courageous you
want the big ticket items you want to
have an
impact and then even if they don't give
you a raise
the experience of being involved makes
you
five times more marketable than you were
before the year started
yeah so you your advice basically is
that
you adopt a much broader mindset which
is
something like how can i be optimally
successful in this company
and what optimal success is going to
require
is being a key player in the most
important things that the company does
that's also going to be allied with the
willingness to take on additional
responsibility
not to see that as a native supporter
people often avoid responsibility but
it's if you can take it on voluntarily
it's there's no difference between
responsibility and opportunity
if the company is offering golf yeah
what is that responsibility too you now
the highest levels of your company
now have an investment in making sure
you succeed
so you just gone from being maybe
somebody struggling by themselves
your responsibilities are critical to
the everybody's future
and everybody has a stake in you doing
well because
that's what you've taken on i mean it's
it's a virtuous cycle if you will yes it
also makes you
difficult to replace and therefore much
more effective than your salary
negotiations
amen absolutely you had some really nice
very practical tips for people
negotiating their initial salary
i thought two of these were really smart
um one was
if if if you're being interviewed for a
new position
and you're asked to define your starting
salary
to offer a range to say something like
well
people in this position are often
offered
125 to 175 000 a year
as a starting salary and to
strategically do that so that
your desired salary is in the bottom end
of that range
i think it falls to that well
yes apparently well it's a good question
yes is the
short answer according to the book but i
it's interesting that you would phrase
it as fall for that because
that is the danger of techniques is that
they can become manipulative
you know so that's why i wanted to talk
about the broader ethic
and you also mentioned that it's smart
for someone who's
negotiating for their first position to
also
negotiate metrics for their first rates
which is even more important right it's
like you could negotiate for how your
salary is going to increase in the
future
rather than how what it's going to be
right at the beginning
but i like michaela's question would you
regard
that offering as a range offering other
range as manipulative
now i'm not manipulative i mean i'm a
nice guy what are you guys talking about
but i regret that it's manipulative
you know all right so and and from some
of the talks
um that that i've heard you give jordan
and some other stuff
you know there's always additional
nuances and factors to consider you want
to stay off of one thing
like first of all just because what
you're worth and what they can pay you
might not line up
and the experience for being there may
be more valuable than the dollars
i got to tell you right now i go work
for minimum wage
to be warren buffett's assistant for a
year i would get him coffee
i would do anything and i and i do it i
might do it for free
because that would be a position where i
would learn so much so you get
it's as much not handcuffing the other
side
and making you somebody they can't get
based on the number
you're looking for a great marriage so
the range
is to feel them out understand
also when you give a range and it and
you the other side's numbers within that
range
they're going to take the end that most
favors them
so if you're going to give a range you
better be willing to accept the bottom
number they're not going to get in the
middle
right right what are the practical
aspects of ranges
question i had in relationship to that
was exactly the manipulative angle i
mean
i guess maybe you could answer it um i
would be happy with something in the
range of 110
000 to 150 000 and
because if you have to point out that
other companies are making offers in
this
range you have to know for sure that
other companies work
there's no sense
adding a falsehood to your negotiation
for the purpose of picking up an
advantage that seems to me to be a very
bad strategy
falsehoods are a bad idea i'm i'm
against any sort of deception by
commission or omission so yeah
especially on that point no i i wouldn't
say something out i didn't know
this accusation audit we should maybe
talk about that a little bit that's that
was
something i found now you derived that
from your analysis of courtroom behavior
of lawyers if i remember correctly
well it added to it i mean you know
seeing it working in different
in different areas it definitely added
to our thinking
what is it if you don't mind
yeah well you know it's first of all
it's uh
you know the the lawyers would call it
getting out the uglies in advance
you know if you gotta if you got a
witness that there's some ugly things
about you bring it up first
let the jury reconcile themselves to it
before they listen to anything else
you know i work with some great
prosecutors when i was with the fbi
southern district in new york
now in in in business it's
understanding what the negatives are in
advance what's crazy is when we begin to
proactively get out in front of them
like if i get if i could get some
let's say you got no negative about me
at all
but i'm getting ready to say something
that you're not gonna like
i'll say look you're gonna think i'm a
real jerk for bringing this up
and then when i bring it up it'll have
far less impact you'll never know what i
headed you off from
and that's why we get really aggressive
with going after the negatives early on
and calling them up
yeah so the accusation audit allows you
to lay out on the table
all the weaknesses of your position and
your character for that matter and so
there's a variety of reasons that that
might be useful one is that
by indicating your willingness to
admit to these faults you showed that
the faults are small enough so that
someone could admit to having them
that's the first thing and the second
thing is you
show yourself as someone who's larger
than their faults because they're
willing to admit to them
right so you minimize the faults in some
sense even though you're presenting them
accuracy
accurately you minimize their emotional
impact or you decrease their emotional
impact
and you increase the
the integrity of your own character at
the same time and again these two things
that should be done honestly not as a
matter of technique
if you do an accusation audit it should
be a genuine one
and you should be doing it in part so
that you this is why i understand
anyway so that you are also as aware as
you get as aware as you need to be
of the shortcomings you have in the
negotiation
yeah i used to do that to you like i
don't know if you remember i remember
i don't know if this was a technique or
just an evil thing to do but i can
remember coming home and saying
i like some sort of terrible thing i am
this isn't exactly the same it's
something that sort of terrible thing
i've done i was like drinking as we're
doing this
this happened just kidding but this
actually did happen and it would be
the second thing would be smaller and i
found that that really worked on not
getting in as well
thank god that didn't happen that's not
an accusation
that's a that's an anchoring technique
correct well you know depending upon how
how you
deployed it there's a combination of
both things yeah
so we could talk about the anchoring
technique as well
we could i mean it's you guys the show
we'll talk about whatever you guys make
me
you got me a hostage here i'm your host
and it sounds like you feel like you're
a hostage
i'll take it all day long uh so what is
what is the anchoring technique would
you describe that
well yeah i mean um the anchoring
technique and we we're very you know you
can anchor on a number
and we don't anchor on numbers but i
will tell you we
we anchor emotionally like
if somebody wants to know what i if
somebody wants to know what i charge for
consulting
i'm going to say hi more than you have
more than you ever paid
and we're not moving forward in this
conversation until you ask me to give
you the number
now in that period of time that you that
we waited
you're going to think it's some crazy
number
and when i give you my number
you're going to say like ah well that
isn't that bad
what comes with that and we now made the
numbers something that that is
irrelevant
what's relevant really in all business
negotiations
is delivery
and we over deliver
so that the anchoring that was a very
subtle
use of anchoring or description of
anchoring their anchoring technique
occurs imagine that you're always
interpreting what's going on within a
context of some sort
and so how big something is
depends on the context and so maybe
you think a house say it's worth 135
000 and you find out the person wants
two and a half million for it well then
if they
come down to 500 000 you're going to
think that's pretty reasonable because
they anchored you at 2 million
even though you thought to begin with it
was only 135
000. so that is what i did
nice yeah it's very very treacherous and
sneaky of you
yeah you still do that
i don't think so i don't think so but
i'm not as debaucherous as i once was
well we gotta raise the level of your
skills we gotta get you guys more money
i you know
we'll go offline and give you some
coaching next time next time you'll be
you'll be in one of five houses that you
wanted to be in you'll have studios all
over the planet you're being fuji
in australia i need help with getting
along for negotiating
i get way too angry and my husband
is he's amazing at it like he's
he said like i read your book and he's a
good negotiator he's married to you
well that's what he said too i was like
i don't get along with you very well and
he's like yeah but look where we are
oh yeah yes you did you will win that
round
okay another another hint you have
neutralize the negative and reinforce
the positive
what do you mean by that yeah well um
simply calling out the negatives has a
neutralizing effect
on them to some degree every time every
single time now how much the effect is
varies but again if we go back to the
neuroscience stuff and the
the amygdala is 75 negative
you neutralize the negative you get an
opportunity for the positive
to pick up some ground if i say
seems like you want to make a deal if
you genuinely do
[Music]
then that will reinforce that feeling
seems like you want a long-term
relationship
seems like terms are important to you
that will reinforce those
positive aspects if i say
seems like you hate uncertainty the
anxiety that you were feeling in the
moment
will diminish how much it diminishes i
may need to neutralize it
several times to get it out of the way
but again our
our neuroscience wiring has laid out a
lot of
what people like you have instinctively
come to know from
your practice in your interaction with
people
where you guys were finding your way
before we could map what was going on
inside the brain
are you married chris i
uh there is the next mrs voss and i'm
looking for the future ex mrs voss
ah did your marriage fail as a
consequence of poor negotiation
no you know what it really failed as a
consequence of what all relationships
fail at
it's no good or no bad but a
misalignment and core values
and there were things that were
important to me that weren't important
to her
and vice versa business relationships
personal relationships
at the end of the day it's no good or no
bad on either side
it's just enough of a difference in core
values
that you're entitled to go your way and
i'm entitled to go mine and nobody's
wrong
right so error-consolable differences
for yeah right well you used to be that
used to be acceptable grounds for
divorce
yeah yeah i mean you're not wrong i'm
not wrong we just don't match up
how have the skills that you learn as a
tactical
hostage negotiator affecting your
your more intimate relationships
you know it's helped me to be more
attentive
um you know it's an ongoing process i'm
still learning i'm still making mistakes
i i hope to be learning and making
mistakes for at least
i i'd say i'm a third of the way through
my life maybe another 100 years
but you know the idea of dialing into
somebody and having a better
long-term relationship and even thinking
about that and getting better on it is
very important to me so
yeah i still make mistakes but you know
i don't i don't want anybody to regret
having had a relationship with me
although some do you think that happens
to everybody
uh how do you negotiate with someone who
is staying on a hostage situation who
doesn't want to talk to you
or isn't communicating other things you
can do to get them
stopping so tightly yeah well
yeah take a step back if somebody's
being tight-lipped
one or two things are happening um first
and foremost is probably they don't feel
like
talking to you is doing them any good
because you're not listening people get
tight-lipped
because communication isn't doing them
any good
now they could be trapped in a corner
and they could be helpless
or you could be not listening the there
are three possibilities another reason
for being tight-lipped
tight-lipped people trust
incredibly and they're a little bit
afraid of how vulnerable they are
because when they trust they go
all in and they've been hurt they've
been badly hurt
so they're cautious because you resemble
somebody that hurt them in the past
so if you think about what the
possibilities are
first of all you know just adapt and
begin look i haven't
clearly i haven't won your trust yet
well if it's not about trust but they're
helpless
they're going to correct they're going
to say no no it's not about trust it's
because i get there's nothing i could do
i'm trapped there's nowhere i could go
but at that moment in time you're in
here now you're in dialogue
understanding what really is dialogue
even denial is dialogue somebody opens
somebody who gives you more than a
one-word response who's previously type
lipped now they're testing to see
if you're going to listen if you're
going to understand
or if you're going to contradict or
argue people are tight-lipped with
other people who are argumented
do you have any or could you tell us one
of your
i don't know if you're allowed to talk
about stones but can you tell us about a
process from the no solution story
is that allowed obviously yeah of course
it's allowed which
there i was terrorists to the left of me
terrorists yeah exactly one of those
you know there were two straight cases
in the philippines and we talk about
both of them
in in the book um one
one the the bad guy on the other side
was sociopathic rape and murder and
killing straight out of the movie's
terrorist
the type of person that empathy is not
supposed to work on
now when do you know when the other side
feels understood when the other side
says
that's right in a critical moment in
that negotiation
and what i really was was an
international negotiation coach i'm
coaching people in countries who were
coachable
and i had i'm coaching a guy named benji
and he's eminently coachable
we summarize the bad guys point of view
you guys have been pressed for 500 years
americans are horrible
philippine government is horrible you
know everything everything he said
500 years worth of emotional baggage
bad guy literally says that's right
in that instance a 10 million dollar
ransom demand
evaporated disappeared went off the
table
a couple of months later we're
continuing in the negotiation no more
monetary demands for the hostage
none non non-monetary demands
continued application of what we now
refer to as tactical empathy
hostage walks away
on monday thursday the thursday before
easter walked away
and back in the philippines three weeks
later connected back up with benji will
work on another case
he says you're not gonna believe who
called me on the phone
the terrorist called him on the phone
to tell him that he respected him
that's powerful stuff because we were
engaged with the same group again
and the guy the terrorist the
sociopathic called
to express his respect for how he was
treated
had lost everything in the negotiation
they wanted 10 million they got zero
so that this stuff works it works on
everybody
it always leaves you better off
does that mean that the this terrorist
wasn't actually interested in the 10
million
he was actually interested in being
understood what would you take away from
that
you know honoring their way through you
know what the other side is always
interested in is the best they could do
one of the things that i learned about
in really kidnapping negotiations
globally
kidnapping is a commodities exchange
they're businessmen on the other side
and what they're really interested in is
the best that they could do
and the best you could do is often
defined by how you feel during the
process of the outcome
so they wanted 10 million dollars or the
best that they could possibly do
what does 10 million dollars buy in this
instance 10 million dollars buys you
influence
they started asking for other things
that bought them influence
let's get certain intermediaries
involved certain politicians
we want access to people if we have more
money what do we spend that money on
ultimately guns what do guns get you
guns get your influence
ultimately people want soft power
so when they started looking for
something else
after having their anger being
deactivated
they also sort of lost control of their
operation which created the
circumstances
of our hostage walking away
uh good things it's it sounds ridiculous
good things fall out of the sky if you
let them happen
and that's one of the reasons to engage
in this approach to negotiation because
something good is going to happen if you
if you if you give it the opportunity
tell me what your company does exactly
now i mean if
you were hired by a by a business yeah
well we could you know we coach we get
hired by businesses all the time but we
really coach high performers to better
lives
you coach the high performers
specifically well
um yeah i mean the people that are drawn
to us are the high performers
um and and our marketing is is we're
pointed much more at individuals and
companies again
we coach companies but companies by and
large are relatively dysfunctional
um daniel coyle and the culture code i
think he pointed out to stat
that only six percent of corporate
executives could actually recite their
corporate values
well in forty percent forty percent of
management have negative net value to
the company
yeah there you go right yeah so you know
these are these are people that are
struggling with themselves let alone new
training
but we coach people into uh
that are making better lives for
themselves and their families
that are top performers i mean typically
people that we coach in negotiations
are cutting two or three life-changing
deals a year
as opposed to one every five or six
years
everybody that's that that we coach
that we were coaching last year are
wealthier right now than they were a
year ago
how do they find me well black swan ltd
is uh is the website black swan ltd.com
you know the first step is a book which
you know you're kind enough to
to look through and appreciate and
and recognize how much that you know
we're in sync with on our thinking
and then come to the website we got free
stuff downloaded subscribe
to our newsletter it's free it's
actionable
give us a chance to to put your family
in a bigger house send your kids to a
better school
your book is titled never split the
difference yeah
so i always thought negotiation meant
somebody has a point of view here and
somebody has a point of view here and
you want to
find middle ground what exactly do you
mean by never split the difference
you know it's it's a two-way street
um but splitting the difference first of
all is a fool's error for a number of
reasons
compromise you know do you compromise
your principles
you know there was a there was a cartoon
about marital uh
a married couple long time ago husband
and wife are talking to each other and
the husband says let's compromise that
way we'll both be unhappy
you know compromise is a way to
guarantee that you're both unhappy
now there's some people that say well a
great negotiation is where both sides
are a little unhappy
is a great marriage where both sides are
unhappy that's a definition of
long-term unhappiness so
besides knowing what you want
don't compromise and meet in the middle
you're both going to be unhappy
now you now what the other side wants
may be even better than what you had in
mind
um a colleague a friend a mentor
somebody we do business with a guy named
dan sullivan recently wrote a book
called
who not how he coaches the greatest
entrepreneurs in the world
he heard me give a talk and he decided
how he was going to take a position with
his partners on his book deal
the book that he just put out the people
that he collaborated with he gave them
every dime because i said sometimes what
the other side wants
give them what they want the guys that
he collaborated with
on that book giving them every dime from
the book because the amount of business
is going to develop for his company
which is going to be huge
they are killing themselves for him i
was not i was on a conference call with
them ben hardy and tucker max tucker max
is a famous author in his own right
tucker says dan got every drop of our
blood
on this book dan gave them every dime
from the book because he knew how much
it was going to bring him long-term
so never split the difference also the
other side give him their position
and they will kill themselves for you
yeah so it's it's interesting
because compromise is a reasonable way
of construing negotiation i think
if you're deadlocked and you have to
make a decision
and and there's also a there's time
pressure
so then it seems to me under those
circumstances that would be a reasonable
heuristic to say well we'll split the
difference and we won't be unhappy
no how dare you i dare you no
no no no no
let me develop that out for a moment
because there is something about
negotiation
that is that is is inextricably
associated with compromise
i don't think that's the best way of
conception conceptualizing negotiation
as such so
see because people are going to listen
to this podcast and they're going to
think
no no no sometimes you have to split the
difference
so my okay i knew that
i want to push you on that because
please me huh don't push me hug me give
me a hug
no no i'm going to go with the push i
think we can hug at the end if it all
goes well
so look if you're negotiating with
your your your child
seven years old and he wants to go to
bed at
9 30 and you want to go to bed at 8 30.
what's wrong with splitting the
difference why not in that situation
split the difference
okay see i see i'm i'm just
i don't think it's reasonable to throw
out the idea that
quantum lines is sometimes not your name
calling how dare you what you call me
any names now well i'm maybe i'm just
digging maybe i'm just digging up the
reasons for the marriage
clash
no sorry
anyway do you
do you think there are any circumstances
under which
the proper way of conceptualizing
negotiation is as compromised
all right so here's the first problem
with compromise and and i know you're
familiar with danny kahneman's
uh prospect theory lost things twice as
much as an equivalent gain
the downward spiral we get into
compromise let's say you and i meet in
the middle
neither one of us are going to felt we
mountain met in the middle
because i'm a human being and i'm wired
so that lost things twice as much as an
equivalent gain
and i believe uh professor connor
actually gave a
nobel prize winning behavioral economics
theory
i think he said that he thinks it's
actually five to seven times as much and
he and amos taversky just said twice as
much so they got fewer arguments
so let's say we meet in the middle let's
say you give in 10.
emotionally you felt you gave 20
and you're not going to feel whole until
you hit me for 20.
now you've hit me for 20 i'm not going
to feel even
until i've hit you for 40. this is a
guaranteed downward spiral
because we're human it's impossible to
compromise
in a way that we both feel is fair even
if the numbers are exactly
the same okay so then you it seems to me
like you would
you're making the case that a
negotiation that ends in compromise
actually failed yeah amen
okay well that's that's worth thinking
about yeah because that would mean that
neither party was able to
switch the conceptual framework around
so that both walked away
enrich exactly if they both are going to
walk away feeling hurt
and it's a recipe for bad bad that ain't
that kind of sustainable
does that imply let's say that in
business negotiation
if you can't negotiate um an arrangement
where you both walk away enriched
and you have to default to compromise
that you should probably walk away
yeah no deal is better than a bad deal
well okay so my question i i actually
agree just from
looking at you're not going to call me
names like you damn no no no i'm
i'm a very nice person that's that's not
even true my dad is a nice person
i know i'm just teasing the bulk of you
i was looking forward to talking to you
guys because
i knew it was going to be fun yeah this
is fun
i'm glad that that weird from a second
ago just happened um
uh so i found that when i'm trying to
negotiate things i'm
angry unless i change my mind or get
what i want
which i think is what you were saying
interesting point yeah
i've never felt okay with the compromise
i so so i kind of get what you're saying
from there
now putting a toddler to bed my go-to
is hey you're three and i'm older than
you
and eight o'clock is the bedtime yeah
it's just powered
it's authority and it doesn't work yeah
it's authority so that's my go-to
now andre my husband negotiates with the
three-year-old
and i go you're insane for negotiating
with three-year-old but he can talk her
into
deciding she wants to go to bed at eight
which is ideal but
when do you use authority or do you just
think that's a bad tactic
well um using authority
um is is bad for you long term um and
in in it because then you
if it's with your children you take
you're conditioning them
that they you can't win without
authority
now and now i would i would ask you to
consider
in your interactions with your children
over bedtime you're trying to get him to
go
go to bed or you're trying to get him to
think and i would offer the larger views
to get him to think
and then then at what age how do you
stimulate that thinking
three is a little early four to five
but you're really teaching your kids to
think all along the way you're showing
them core values
and if you're getting your way with your
kid based on authority
what kind of a core value are you
showing now there are
times children need discipline human
beings
human beings need boundaries because it
makes them feel secure
stability you can say that about 50
times i would say
yeah yeah everybody everybody needs
stability
predictability you know uh
predictability
turns into trust you know you
you your kids need to know if you're
gonna set a line and how are you gonna
set that line
and then are you going to encourage them
to think and become better people
and we have we a lot of people use never
split the difference
in their interactions with their kids
and we get funny
feedback like you know i've cut 15
minutes off
uh bedtime or you know 20 minutes off
preparation time to go to bed
and then the interactions with the
children are different this is this is
human nature stuff this is really about
human nature
how about business stories let's
let's let's walk through let's walk
through like a particularly successful
transformation that you've seen
on their clients something like that
wow yeah um well the first one that
springs to mind
uh you know because my students at the
at the business schools
were my clients my customers i was
coaching them into better deals
one of my students uh is is doing a
negotiation to come on with the company
and he's
he's the best person for the job he's
worth more than what they're offering
and what and the job is worth more than
what they're offering he said when i
didn't pass i can't get any more out of
it
i said write down a list of questions
that you would ask where the answer
would be yes
that would prove your case now flip
all those questions on its head
and make every one of them a no oriented
question
and you'll be shocked what you can get
away with getting somebody to say no
you know do you do you want me to fail
you want to lose the best person for the
job do you want the person that takes
this job to fail
he flipped all his yes questions to no
questions he came back to me said the
the salary offer that they put on the
table was so much higher than what they
were authorized to do
they had to go to the cfo to give them
permission to do the deal
another job negotiation young man
is a top analyst in his company making
boatloads of money for his company
wants to go back and renegotiate his his
compensation package the important thing
here too is the other side
doesn't feel beaten he goes to his boss
and he says
you know i'm earning more more for you
than anybody else is
i deserve a race and his boss says yeah
you know
those are all true but i don't see how i
can give you a raise that's
fair to everybody else who's been here
longer than you and have put more of
their life into this company than you
so you come back to me in two weeks if
you can come up with a plan that shows
how we can do this fairly i'll give you
the raise
he comes back two weeks later the boss
said did you come up with a plan and he
said no
the boss said why not he says well
you make a great point there's no way to
do this that's
fair to everybody else and the boss said
yeah but it's not an issue of fairness
to everybody else it's an issue of how
profitable you are for the company
and he gave him the deal gave him a
better salary compensation which was his
boss's idea because he deactivated the
negative thinking he had in his head
which was interfering with it and he
came back to us and he said
this is going to change my life
and that's the kind of stuff we get from
our our clients all the time
how big is your organization
right now we've got 15 people in the
company and do they all do
coaching of the sort that you've been
describing no we've got
we've got five coaches and
we've got some business development
people you know we've got
back office people that keep our coaches
and our business development people on
tap we got a great team sure
sure so um
if i came to you for your services
how would we start the process
what would happen would i have to come
to you with like a specific business
case or are you training me as an
individual
more broadly both we do both we get we
get a lot of people that will
come to us for coaching and specific
deals
and we'll build a strategy in that's
gonna
that's going to accelerate it to its
best outcome
in a third of the time probably less
now the best outcome might be that you
stop wasting your time in this deal and
move on there's a there's a phrase in
sales it's not a sin to not get the deal
it's a sin to take a long time to not
get the deal
yeah yeah right absolutely and that
that's a yeah though
those are the deals where the terrible
ones are
where it looks like something might
happen yeah i hope
why people say hope is not a strategy
hope might just kill your profitability
because you're never going to get the
deal
so we'll coach you through specific
deals and
typically almost everybody that we've
coached in a deal not only wants more
for them but they want more for people
in their company we just
one executive we've been coaching for a
year just signed up all of his
executives for individual coaching
because we're making them so much money
yeah well one of the things you mention
here too is that
that no when when the person you're
negotiating with says no
that isn't necessarily such a bad thing
and you should stop thinking that it's a
bad thing so it doesn't scare you and
it's one of the advantages to know also
know
if it's true no tells you what a dead
end actually
is and so if it's genuine though you
don't have to go sniffing down that
trail anymore and that can stalk you
from
the death by hope which really can
really be a catastrophe
like that's right give you the magic
words
you hit the nail on the head yeah not
wasting your time
and since since we've really and this
has been since the book came out it's
something we call proof of life for the
favor
of the fool if you don't know who the
fool in the game is it's probably you
if you're the fool in the game you got
to find out get out of the game go play
with somebody else
at least 20 percent of every 20 percent
of all business
opportunities are full in the game
what would happen if you got rid of 20
of the the deals were you just spending
your wheels
you don't even have to get any better
you just get
get rid of the stuff that's killing your
time
certain things like that can really
accelerate your success
any tips on how you might identify
pitfalls like that i mean
a clear failure is merciful in some
sense
as we do we've been skirting around that
definition
clear failure is most important it's
it's chasing the thing that never
appears that kills you
how do you how do you start
understanding when you should quit
well the more focused in a business
interaction more focus somebody is on
price like right off the bat if they're
pushing you really really hard for a
price
90 of the time you're the competing bit
you know
and the world is even though i live in
vegas the world is las vegas rules you
got to get off of the
out of the game where you're winning 15
of the time and you got to get into the
game where you're winning 70 to 75
percent of the time
the more they're pushing you on price
it's a data point your competing bid
so that's your first instinct
so your second your second fatal right
there right
now now the next thing is i you you ask
somebody what we
refer to as a visioning question if they
have any intention of moving forward
with you
which makes you the favorite then you
say all right so
how would where would how do we move on
from here
if they are at complete loss for words
then they have no intention of moving on
with you because they didn't envision it
before the comments
that's i really like that so that's
really smart so you
you ask the person that you're
discussing the situation with
what how they would envision this
relationship
if it was successful and if they can't
tell you anything
then then it isn't obvious at all what
they're doing in the negotiation
they might be doing what you said with
regards to price they're paying you off
against
their their true supplier let's say
right right
right so what you're negotiating that
it's such such a useful way of thinking
about that i mean
you know when you're starting a business
with someone it's pretty self-evident
that
you need to develop a shared vision
otherwise you wouldn't be undertaking
that adventure let's say
it's really easy when you have a
business to think that what you're doing
is
selling you know you have a product and
you're selling it
but it's much more useful i think
to think about it as if you are
expanding your business and taking on
your new
buyer as a partner because that's
actually what you're doing it works
properly
so you're inviting them into your
business and that means your business
has to shift
and change and so does theirs and you
both have to see that as a positive
thing
and if that isn't happening then the
sale isn't going to occur
because you're actually not selling
you're actually trying to build a
relationship
right right and you know what even if
they want to proceed with you you might
not want that relationship that's part
of it too
yes absolutely they lay out a vision
where
you know what they're doing is not good
for you
oh yeah i mean that's where yes is a big
problem is you end up with
i mean i i i had a business deal
arranged with a large corporation in the
united states um
10 years ago we were thrilled about it
and then the ceo got
fired a week later and
the deal just fell apart we'd be
negotiating it for about a year and a
half
and it was literally on his desk to sign
and he was replaced and so
it just killed it but a month and a half
later we were
unbelievably relieved because we
realized that we would have had to have
done
all sorts of work for the company that
we would never got paid for and it would
have taken on it was
a responsibility that was completely
incommensurate with the rewards
and so that was a good situation where
yes would have been a catastrophe so
i guess partly what you have to do is
not assume that no is a disaster
and not assume that yes is a blessing
you have to sit back and see if the
vision as you pointed out is
is worthy of pursuing that you're both
committed to it
yeah what's the how what's the how how's
this how how is
yes there's nothing without how i mean
how is everything
or yes it's even dangerous about how
yeah well yeah i mean yes without how is
is a train wreck coming at you is
however long that relationship
lasts it's gonna it's gonna be blood
money
it's gonna be painful it's gonna take
years off your life you're gonna want
that time back
yeah exactly exactly an opportunity you
wish you didn't have
yeah yeah and you know we have those
occasionally that's why we decide you
know we have bad relationships
so look i used to i did a lot of
executive coaching
um and like you i my clientele were
high performers we asked the companies
with whom we worked to send us their
high performance
and we would increase their productivity
now
i basically worked for the individual
not for the company
right and my goal was to make their life
better
on the assumption that that would make
them more productive
and so i did counter-intuitive things
for example with the lawyers i worked
with most of them took far more
vacations after they worked with me for
a few months
but their productivity went up yeah but
our
our strategy my strategy was
to help the person develop an
overarching vision for their life
um that was well balanced and
iterable you know because your life has
to be sustainable
if it's if it's if it's to allow it has
to be sustainable
if it's not sustainable by definition it
leads you downhill
and to be sustainable it has to be
developed in a variety of areas
you can't sacrifice one thing to another
too great or you'll fall apart across
time
how much do you think success in
business and success and negotiation is
dependent on the development of a global
vision for
for what constitutes a successful life
because if you're negotiating you need
to know why you're negotiating and
that's a deep question why
yeah i think completely you know where
where is this taking me vision drives is
the decision it's it's astonishing what
people will do
if they feel it's taking them someplace
wonderful
yes and they won't do the simplest
things that they
find feel either useless or taking them
to a bad place
yes well thank god for that right
because why should you do something
unless it's taking you somewhere better
right yeah yeah so yeah the vision
vision drives decision where's this
taking us
and and that and that is almost all and
it's in the head anyway
that is so and you know it's interacting
with me
it just makes you happier to start with
you're going to want more of it if you
know that i'm dedicated
to your success as well as my own
then you can trust me with your secrets
and we'll come up with a better deal
because you see
that i'm a great long-term partner
what's a long-term relationship i'm
dedicated
to to you being happier i mean it's one
of the reasons people in my company and
we love working together because we love
helping people plus we're all helping
each other to a better life
yeah so i was going to ask you about
your vision like if you had to
articulate your vision
what what would that be what would the
articulation be
the vision from for for me for my life
or for for the people that i work with
well both both i'd be interested in both
of those
your life specifically but also that
obviously because you work with these
other people
your vision of yourself has to have
their
has implications for how you're
interacting with them
so first of all for people to be happier
in their day-to-day interactions
what do you mean by what do you mean by
happening i have a specific reason for
asking this because
you already mentioned that people are
much more averse to loss
than they are um thrilled by game
right a lot of times when people talk
about happy what they mean
is less misery rather than more positive
emotion right they need less misery
less uncertainty less pain less threat
that's right
right right so when you say happier do
you mean happier do you mean
more secure and yeah i mean you know we
are
uh across the board the people that we
that we work with
that i work with that that we coach
we enjoy what we're doing um we don't
feel like we're doing anything anybody's
expense
right we don't feel like we're
exploiting anybody
our clients on a regular basis
are not just making more money but
enjoying their jobs
more and we
weekly we had a meeting earlier today we
were sort of wrapping up 2020
where we completely pivoted our business
had a ball
dealing with the crisis because we work
so well together as a team
[Music]
and are actually serving more people
and you know it's not our primary
objective
but we're more profitable this year than
we were last year
which means we get to do more next year
we get to meet more cool people the peop
the people that we meet on a regular
basis
who want to get better and want to make
the world a better place
are fun people to be around oh yeah
that's a good deal
that's a good deal
yeah so you know like i mentioned dan
sullivan earlier
he's an interesting cat you know
everybody stephen cutler i get
interactions with stephen kotler one of
the most interesting guys on the planet
because he's about making the world a
better place
these are fun people to be around
you're fun
am i fun i think it's fun i'm fun when
i'm on
i'm not fun when i'm not alone watching
questions
uh i think that i think it's actually
time and i think i think we're done
so thank you so much for coming on uh i
was incredibly interested to
talk to you i really like the
fact that i really like i've never split
the difference that really
um really resonated with me
because whenever i do some sort of
compromise i feel like i've lost
it doesn't work i also really enjoyed
being
if you know that never if you don't
never split the difference then maybe
you should just walk away
and i think that's really important to
know that maybe you don't want to
if you can't come to a compromise and
make both people happy maybe you don't
want to
have a relationship with that person i
think that's really
valuable
um where you mention a couple places
people can find you
uh what are your social media all right
so i'm
uh uh at the fbi negotiator on instagram
um but really the best way for us to
help people as much as they want we got
we got a free negotiation newsletter we
put out
it's not so important that it's free
what's really what's best about it it's
concise it's a short read
i mean some people put out newsletters
and they're 15 articles you don't know
what to do it
the newsletter is a gateway to
everything we have and if i may
um for uh the website is
blackswanltd.com
b-l-a-c-k-s-w-a-s-w-a-n-l-t-d
dot com we've got a text to sign up
function
also which is simple it only works in
the us and i'm sure you've got a global
audience
but in the us if you text to the number
3377
3377 send a message black swan
method three words uh capitalization
doesn't matter
space between each word you get a dialog
box back if you want only if you want
sign up for the newsletter we'll help
you we'll move you forward we
we we love helping people
provide have just have more fun and have
more
i'm fine i need that
it's great meeting you that was an
absolute pleasure being on with both of
you guys
lovely talking with you yeah and good
luck baby i i hope that
you do continue succeeding in your
attempts to
help people help themselves and by
helping to make the world a better place
but shade as that might sound it's
unless it's replaced by a better
philosophy it's pretty good one
it'll do yeah it'll do it it'll do yeah
my pleasure thanks guys
[Music]
you